Today is my notice I am google android developer
I belong to the relations team
This video introduces new features for developers of KitKat Android 4.4
I will
Kit Kat is only 0.1 when it sees only the version number but it is actually a lot
Has a new api added
At the time of development of the jelly bean, the main focus was on smooth operation
Memory optimization in this kit cut
It can be said that the main focus is on improving the efficiency of use of ram
android 4.4 leaves the smoothness of the jelly bean
Works with a much wider range of terminals than ever before
It corresponds to the terminal that the installed ram capacity is limited to 512 mb
Thai enthusiasts use the app ram under development with several new apis and tools
You can check the efficiency
The new api is running on a terminal with limited memory when the app is launched
Is
activity manager is low ram device
You can check using
By enduring yesterday's behavior which eats memory according to the value or restricting some functions
Providing an excellent user experience even on terminals with limited RAM capacity
I can do it
It is a last resort to limit the y and y functions
First of all, if you refer to this document, without reducing the function
You can check the know-how to optimize the free efficiency etc.
How to use the memory of the application in the first place to actually work to improve the efficiency of ram utilization
You need to understand what you are doing
The new Prox tool is about app execution time and memory usage
Provide useful data for analysis
Prox standing can be called from adb
adb shell is a command called dump and sprout start
If you're not good at the command line, you'll be fine
Process all android 4.4 terminal and emulator processes with options
You can analyze the memory profile of the app on the Developer Options screen of the statistical information
I will
There is a blue list of the system Mari's overview
The overall memory load of each app is displayed
In addition, he used to have time for each app to go out in background
is
Selecting an app gives an overview of the memory consumption and the running time of that app and the average maximum
ram usage is displayed
Memory usage efficiency is not only KitKat has a beautiful ui ux design
There are several new methods to offer you
First the android design guidelines have been updated
In the color beity section that users get impressed by referring to the latest guidelines
Please provide a unique experience
For details, check the latest contents of the android design action program
Please give me
As a new api, full screen ima-branch mode added new
Transitions framework supports fresh animation
Subtitle display support
New tools for high quality screen recording are provided
Use the new full screen Well Chapter mode to take advantage of the high quality ui that takes advantage of every corner of the screen
You can develop
System ui status bar The navigation bar is hidden and the app is
You can react to events in any place
Providing visually rich content through this
For example, to enhance the user experience of photo video map e-books and games
I can do it
This full-screen now branch mode can be controlled with an eye flag of two things
I will
I am now sticky and Ishibu club
The code looks like this You can now turn on and off the branch flag
Also now if the branch sticky flag is used then the system ui has been a while
Automatically hide or hide automatically when the user touches the middle part of the screen
Full Screen Now Branch Mode Available
For more information about the old nest proximal well branch mode
Look at the program called Doubly in the now branch mode that Rick of Romans has released
Please give me
Real-life high-quality fresh animation To go simply
The new Transitions framework in android 4.4
api has been added
It is ui corresponding to the change of the situation so that the person of the user can understand easily if this is used
It can be elegantly written to express animation
The new Transitions framework allows developers to define scenes
Scene fibers are such view hierarchies and transitions
A combination of animated fibers
You can hurt the animation notation when the user enters and leaves the scene
Match some predefined transitions from layout to display hide
Available
Fade in fade out automatically when the scene changes
Automatic transitions such as moving and resizing are also available
Also, custom transitions that animate any property specifically for that app
You can also define your own and plug in your own animation style
I will
More in detail is the program called Transitions
Animation specialist Chet Hase from the android team explains
Please check it by all means
Android 4.4 system settings and to improve the accessibility of the app
The subtitle display setting has been added
Users can choose subtitle settings common to previous apps
New caption ring manager while referring to the settings for the video playback application
Control subtitles through
Subtitle data stream if the app uses video view
You can add web vtt format to regular video stream
Video view automatically controls subtitle display according to user settings
More specifically, it is in the soldier who implemented this that is a devil-byte program by Alan Billet
Please take a look
People who have tried to manually show the app demo screen with a video camera have a new screen recording
Understand the merit of being able to record the screen of the functional terminal as it is to mp 4 file
I think you can
Recording is done at any bandwidth bit rate supported by the terminal
The aspect ratio of the recorded file will be the same as the screen
Use the adb command to perform screen recording
Record without adb shell screen or at command line
eclipse and android studio
It can also be called from the ddms panel
kitkat adds api for several large new storage areas
Has been
New storage access framework
And new sms content providers
New storage access framework allows users to view and open document images
When choosing a storage provider on the terminal local or in the cloud
Provide fly mark
First of all, as a client-side scenario, the developer provides an application for browsing and managing content
Storage access framework create document if
Use Intents or Open Document Intents
The android platform does standard ui display and users like it
You can choose a document provider
As a provider-side scenario, the storage provider will be your own development
If you do, you can implement the documents provider derived class
Please give me
Overriding these four methods will be your provider file
Read and write functions for any data that is expressed locally or in the cloud
Can be provided
After overriding the intent filter for the documents provider
Attached to the government's promise
Please request permission to manage wood
This will register your provider with the storage access framework
Users will be able to choose from standard ui
On the terminal where your provider app is installed, other client side apps
When trying to access a file using the storage access framework
Allows user users to access your provider's content
I will
I met my colleague in New York
About the storage access framework from both providers
I think that you can confirm this fat byte original program that we are explaining by all means
Now
If you have ever developed an app that uses sms, this new
Please use the official api for sms support
This api is newly added to sdk
An api centered on the use of the sms content provider
Also, the context when receiving a message or writing a message to a provider is slightly
It has been changed
When the sms message arrives the platform directly
Send to default sms message app
This communication is done through the river intent with sms other apps messages
Can be monitored through the sms receive degree intent on
I can do it
The ability to write to the sms provider is selected as the default
There will be only the sns app
Apps that are not selected as default can also send sms messages
I can do it
In this case the platform will instead write to the sms provider
Do
This results in the user having selected those messages as default sns
It is possible to check in the app
More about these sms epia by Adam Sass
Please check the program by all means
And with android 4.4, there are various functions to communicate with surrounding devices.
Addition is being done
Eg new bluetooth profile bluetooth hid
Overgat profile
Aka hog p It consumes low power like mouse x stick keyboard
Provides fast communication between devices and apps
And message exchange at short distance by bluetooth map
Supported
Also, ir blaster function is newly defined as a function of platform standard.
I will
Check the terminal's infrared oscillator with the new api and check its communication frequency
Follow
You can also send signals using infrared communication
Added support for nc's host card emulation feature
Host card emulation function enables various secure nfc communication
For example, the usage such as payment coupon access card traffic pass can be considered
At this time your app can emulate the nfc smart card directly
Can
Implementation of secure element is not necessary
A new reader mode is also supported and your app is a host card
Take on the role of leader in emulation card communication and other nfc communication
Can also
ando host card emulation with iso 7816 plans
Can emulate a smart card based on the 14434 communication standard
I will
Application identifier is defined by the standard iso 7 should be 78164
Dynamically based on the way the communication takes place with the correct android app
Will be routed
The printing function is now supported by platform standard
Print together via wi-fi and print service on the cloud
For example, an api for managing google cloud print is also provided.
I will
Apps support printing of almost any kind of content with these new apis
I can do it
Terminal local image, data on document network, etc.
You can print anything you can draw on canvas
pdf data is the basic format for printing on android
In general, print a bitmap by using a helper class
You can create pdf data with the page properly described
Print api is provided for java and for web view ferper
I will
Generate pdf data with standard android drawing api
receive
The app prints pdf data for printing in exactly the same way as drawing content on the screen
Can be generated
My cousin's mystery Maridoris is an introduction to the print api and a debrief to introduce best practices
We release byte program
Please take a look
KitKat has introduced a new maintenance method to save sensor power consumption
For example, a badge for sensor processing
This is to collect sensor measurement values ​​separately rather than collectively
Schedule and keep the terminal in low power state until the next batch acquisition
Developers specify time intervals for batch acquisition or force measurements before the next feeling comes
You can request the acquisition of
Also two new combined sensors are supported
A walk detection and pedometer
Both can be implemented with hardware to reduce power consumption
So far we have told the atmosphere of some of the api
Besides that, the implementation of the web view is completely new based on chromium
became
Support high performance of the latest standard plan
Provides excellent compatibility
Most of the html 5 features of chrome for android are available
With the new javascript engine va
Is installed
The new api also adds support for the right to left language
Was
For example, horizontal flip of drawing or pseudo locale can be used
Declare the draw bubble as automirrored according to the user's locale
Platform will automatically do spot disease
You can reduce the duplication of several resources in the app
Added support for light and left pseudo locales in developer options
The layout of the screen is
The language displayed in the right to left direction will remain the same
Because of this right to left the layout area of ​​the app even if you can not read the language
You can use it when debugging
And there is good news for those who need fast calculations
Render script is faster
In addition, in android 4.4 render script direct call from c ++
can do
ndk's new c ++ api renders scroll like java
It is an api that calls the function with the RIP
Script instruction custom kernel functionality is also available from c ++
Last but not least, some security issues in android 4.4
Enhancements have been made
First of all android se relaxation setting becomes garden 4 bedding from par 3 branch
Was
Cryptographic algorithms have also been enhanced
Support for Elliptic Curve Digital Signature Algorithm Added to Kiss and Provider
Also
Script key diversion function This is implemented enhancement of key co-op function
More protection for encryption keys when disk space is encrypted
And there is big news related to android 4.4
A new terminal has been announced
It is Lexus 5
Please check and purchase the latest information on Google Play.
And we hope that you develop a nice app
android 4.4 sdk is currently from sdk manager
It is available for download
Please use this to start updating your code
For more detailed api features new features changes please
Please visit the developer. Android. Com website
thank you very much